so obviously these are trying times of
course we're uh you know
racial tensions are at an all-time high
you know people are looting things are
out of control and we need leaders in
the communities to come out
and to you know calm people down and try
to create a message of peace
and uh unity so diddy
diddy you talking about puff daddy
it's diddy now oh okay uh uh mr p diddy
decided uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna fix everything
so he decides hey
we're gonna have a black leadership
conference on youtube
awesome and as part of the panel of our
black leadership conference we're going
to invite uh such famous black
luminaries as
amy schumer and
sean king
and it was the most it was the most
panned thing
i've ever do even in the middle of
nationwide riots
twitter was like oh come on are you
[ __ ] kidding me
oh it was trending
even as riots were going on it was
hilarious
i live in new york and uh
first of all i was really bummed out her
name was amy
as i said it's not doing you any favors
right now right now
right they look like these chicks you
know like i look like
you look like the lady that was stealing
the lamps at target look i'm gonna say
something it's gonna be pretty
controversial and some of you guys are
not gonna believe me but royce will back
me up here
amy schumer
was a piece i asked she used to be very
when she was young she was very pretty
there was oh yeah
i know some of you younger folks are
going to go no you're [ __ ] i'm i'm
telling you
there was
maybe a one year window there where she
would where you were like yeah yeah amy
schumer could get it
what the i've never seen somebody
fall apart like this
she mean she did i i i mean let me see
if i was she a 10 no but she could get
it
not every girl you [ __ ] gonna be at
ten she was never a ten
but you know she was a hard seven
seven point five she could get it at one
point
and i don't know what happened but my
god
carbs
i mean yeah but still man jesus christ
some girls get ch see what i mean come
on
you're [ __ ] nuts that's what you're
doing
yeah you're nuts if you wouldn't have
[ __ ] that chick you're insane is she a
10 no
come on
you're really letting your hatred of amy
schumer blind you if you don't admit
that you probably would have [ __ ] that
i would have [ __ ] that you back in the
day it was like amy schumer she could
get but this
dude go look at that
and then go back to the
go back to the [ __ ]
same person
jesus christ
excuse me we want a table
sooner than that you know like i look
like the
um is she trying to be funny
it made me feel to be honest like
aside from
heartbroken like it made me feel furious
and i
and uh
and like i was she couldn't put makeup
on for this wanted like she lost her job
she'll never get another job
but i wanted she's storing food in her
cheeks for the winter like i don't know
what's going on with her but
who's she talking about this other amy
person she's talking about i don't even
know she's still [ __ ] no idea no clue
no idea but we got it it should
it should
because of what she was
like that kind of false information
and those false claims like could have
led to real
true physical harm or death and
like there i i mean
[Music]
this is going great
i mean like it it
is somebody vacuuming
apparently maybe her [ __ ] guys
and for different reasons but they both
felt equally severe to me and the thing
that annoyed me the most about her was
because i bet if you looked on her
instagram i bet at some point she has
like a black lives matter post
did they think this was gonna be like
getting the amy schumer star power could
you please
let out of touch rich jewish woman from
the upper west side finish your point
royce about racial you're right i'm
really sorry please i got you could you
please let people the niece of chuck
schumer of course who sits on the senate
uh finance committee could you please
let her finish telling us about how
we're racist and wrong and how we have
too much privilege please royce please
let her finish
she looks like current nick
schwarzenegger
that's a good point yeah she does don't
know even what's inside them and it's
it's everyone together it's it's a
systematic
deep problem
that
in my experience
in your experience of what of your early
when you're when you were [ __ ] early
edgy girl and justin neck was writing
your jokes you were making fun of black
people more than anybody else she was
watch her early stand up stuff watch it
when watch it when she watch it when she
still looked like when she still looked
like this
her jokes were way different than when
she looks like this
you know
the only way to really see somebody says
she looks like mario batali
is to
is to have people of color at in in the
highest positions of power you didn't
call them people of color when you were
making fun of them in your early
specials amy when you were [ __ ]
middle act for jimmy norton you weren't
calling them that
that's not what you were you weren't
calling them people of color
i remember oh
i remember what you were calling him amy
and it wasn't people of color that's for
sure
that's the only way and what i've
learned this year
in the last couple years is
you know you know you want to talk about
feminism
but
you need to put people of color and
especially women of color first as so
feminism isn't enough but when you have
feminism
the these little this [ __ ] [ __ ]
these little compartmentalized groups
that they make it's like well we're
gonna have one group of feminism we're
going to have another subgroup of black
feminists and then trans feminists are
going to be in a smaller subgroup
because they're bigger shut up
as next in line
to have people be paying attention and
realize and i'm sorry i'm not like um
i'm smart
not pretty
funny
little commentator or whatever and i
feel like but
that's all you do now
i'm not like a political commentator or
whatever but body positivity and blacks
and like you know oppression and social
justice but like i'm not like you know
ugh
you know
i had i had a baby a year ago except
what you don't say no she ate a baby
okay that makes sense
it's a baby
they dropped the bait they dropped the
baby down like the goat in jurassic park
oh they just deep fry it real quick like
the oreos at the carnival
but i want it now i just deep fry flash
deep fryer fast like a funnel cake it's
like when mo got the deep fryer
[ __ ] i had a baby year ago and and
and the things that i've learned about
the mortality rates for women of color
but who go into hospitals what does that
have to do with your bed so i'm a white
jewish woman who had a baby recently so
then i started reading a lot about the
mortality rate of black women for some
reason i don't know about that i don't
know about it
is she high right now
i don't know man
all the information that i've
that i that was new to me is it's it's
really overwhelming and you know
there's a couple so wait a second
the mortality rate
of black women in hospitals has really
affected her
she's in a lot of pain mike
look at the pain she's in
it it is
people need to be looting amy schumer's
house
if you want if you want equality
you burning her house down go to her
deep freeze there's a whole cow in there
unfortunately there's no blacks in the
upper west side so
a couple things a bunch of never opened
p90xc dvds
but i i'm doing to try to have a [ __ ]
treadmill with dust on it
a fridge full of soda and a bunch of
unread texts from jim norton
[Laughter]
hey amy if you ever want to come on the
jim and sam show you know it's
right up the street we'll send a car for
you a bunch of empty packets of double
stuffed oreos
well but it just feels like
such little change the transcript for
her husband's new book he's working on
how to cook if you're [ __ ] that's a
good one
a box full of love letters from anthony
jesselnik
a signed photo of dolph zigler
which is literally worthless
no oddly enough she doesn't have that
she has a signed photo of zack ryder
because she's not even even she's not a
fan of dolph ziggler
a stack of dvds of all her failed pilots
oh [ __ ]
see we could laugh at times like this
guys
in so much time
well um uh thank you for sharing that
that position schumer
went on the breakfast club and was
highly disappointed that it wasn't what
she thought it was
she came in with a napkin tucked into
her collar already
and charlemagne's like [ __ ] what are
you doing like we don't even
[ __ ] you mean and now we ain't serving
no omelet [ __ ] the [ __ ] is wrong with
you oh [ __ ] um
i was under the impression there'd be
breakfast
julia betsy goes she has a photo silver
silverman with her eyes scratched out
she sits down and starts barking her
order out at charlemagne because she
thinks he's a waiter
yeah i'll start off with coffee and
maybe an apple juice don't [ __ ] mean
i ain't a waiter [ __ ]
it's a radio show
some [ __ ] bunch of books that say
joke structure for dummies [ __ ] coming
in here shouting out orders like this is
shony's [ __ ] is wrong with you this
[ __ ] out of here i don't need this
[ __ ]
perspective um you mentioned it's
something that you said a minute ago and
i don't want to put words in your mouth
so correct me if i'm wrong yeah cause
it's not cake
enough
take it seriously but it's loading going
on
but you said you don't think enough uh
we uh amy cooper for those who don't
know she uh she did lose her job she
lost her dog as well um who's amy cooper
was that the wife from hanging with mr
cooper by the way jh doesn't stand for
jemele hill it stands for jewish hand
puppet
oh i didn't know that
and amy schumer just stands for amy
schumer yeah a lot of people seem a
little bit more concerned about the dog
than actually some of the interaction
but beside the point um i think you
mentioned or you said that um enough no
guys that's not tim dillon on the right
stop that's not nice to tim dillon
really it's mean to him
i just think like the equality and [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] you know if i have
black people are gonna kill them all
time i would have said this years ago
when i was in new york but now i'm in
l.a and it's just totally wrong what's
going on with these people oh amy cooper
is the one that is the video of that
woman that had her dog and was basically
choking the dog because she is she
related to mr cooper
i already made the joke i said is that
is that a hang of mr cooper's wife
know if you guys know this but since
christian cooper has felt some level of
guilt
for all the things that that have
happened he's commented on that and said
that while he he considered her apology
to be genuine
and he thought that the consequences
were too severe
but she should never work again she
should never have a job again she should
be relegated to slavery for the rest of
her life for the ultimate sin of being
racist that's right folks races
shouldn't be allowed to work